[Music]
the mp's own major local hospital saint
thomas's is on the labour list along
with 300 others however many hospitals
opt out in the end it'll be a slow
process do you think there's a need for
changes in the law
i think the chain we have to look quite
seriously
thank you very much indeed
you're looking forward to the summit
very interesting
right i'm assuming this is being
recorded
you're
[Music]
you're very good you know where all the
hot buttons are
yes he is that's reverse he occasionally
presses a little too hot i can tell i
can talk
so obviously since we're opposed to the
death penalty we're in exactly the
position that she doesn't oppose his
execution adam
excuse me that is just enough thank you
very much
now on identity cards
what do you have for breakfast then this
morning
you know one of the things i'm going to
miss is your smiling face at the press
conference
how many we must have done what do you
think 10 press conferences
yeah 20. been alleged that you don't
like the brits because of what they did
to your grandfather yeah i've always
been curious
about this allegation i love
uh the brits we have suggested to you a
very clear way of communicating is
simply to debate with your opponents and
you can't seem to make up your mind on
that nothing about not making my mind
there
what is your decision i'm sorry adam
there is a time for that thank you very
much indeed gordon brown
thank you see you you're staying here
you're staying here
welcome to the sky news leaders debate
round two of the first ever televised
prime ministerial debates in the uk
you are responsible for managing the uk
are you well i'm responsible if you lose
scotland you'd have to go with one no i
don't accept that sky news is projecting
that the uk has voted out
welcome to all out politics a new
program here on sky news fit for purpose
for a post-brexit world i'm gonna get a
lot of abuse back from people who have
fed up with me these days okay i've set
up this being stuck in the traffic
okay which they i'm afraid rightly blame
you you used to be the richest man in
the world i think you're now the second
richest man in the world considerations
on that all right we've got about 30
seconds anybody got the answer to the
housing crisis no